hi everyone it's Ria today I'm going to
show you how to make box mac and cheese
fancy but easy way first I have to learn
how to open the box
according to the Box instruction let's
make the cheese sauce butter it's butter
it's melted our milk cheese package
macaroni is ready let's get fancy I
chilled mac and cheese in the fridge
about 15 minutes golf ball I made 12
volts but this is not fancy yet to add
some water whisk them together mac and
cheese ball called wheat flour in egg
wash cold with breadcrumbs fry until
golden brown about three minutes flip
and it's ready to come out crispy and
golden brown chives for color
nice box mac and cheese Croquettes with
Americans vinaigrette AKA brunch
very fancy